actor Wilson Cruz opens up about losing  his close relative in the Orlando  shooting on Monday the 42 year old actor  opened up to each about losing his mom's  stepsister Brenda Leigh Marquez McCool  who died in the horrific massacre at  pulse nightclub early Sunday the red  band society star explained quote Brenda  went to pulse the way she frequently did  with her 21 year old openly gay son  Isaiah they loved to go there on that  night because it was Latin night and  they could be with their friends dance  salsa and find refuge in a safe space  he also lamented she and her joy for  life were taken away from us and we are  devastated Cruz shared this sweet snap  of Brenda with a touching tribute on his  Facebook he wrote this was the last time  I saw Brenda McCool she was a fighter a  cancer survivor  a stellar mother a proud and fierce  advocate for her LGBT family I can't  believe she's gone I'm mourn with her  kids and my entire family the violence  and hate has to end